welcome to Kupa cloud drawing board
where we do de la way through the cloud
today's topic what is cloud sequel cloud
sequel is a fully managed relational
database for my sequel Postgres sequel
and sequel server it reduces maintenance
cost and automates database provisioning
storage capacity management replication
and backups it offers quick setup with
standard connection drivers and built-in
migration tools top sequel is easy to
set up you select the region and zone
where you would like the instance to be
and it gets created there you also have
a lot of configuration options where you
can select the machine type with the
right number of CPU and amount of memory
you need do storage type between solid
state and hard disk drives depending on
latency queries per second and cost
requirements and set storage capacity
higher storage capacity leads to better
performance cloud sequel also offers
automated backups and Recovery Options
you can set time slots and locations for
backups for production applications it
is recommended to enable high
availability or h.a by enabling this
feature the database instance will
automatically feel over to another zone
in your selected region in case of an
outage you can also create cross
regional replicas to protect from
regional failures in addition you can
enable automatic storage increase to add
more storage
when nearing capacity now how can you
migrate an existing my sequel database
to cloud sequel cloud console makes it
very easy by providing a migrate data
button which guides you through easy
steps first you provide your datasource
details things like public IP address
port number and your replication
credentials second you create a cloud
sequel read replicas just like we
discussed in the creation process using
a sequel dump file third you sync the
read replicas with source and finally
you promote the read replicas two
primary instance with very low downtime
is data safe in cloud sequel well just
like anything else in Google cloud the
data in cloud sequel is encrypted at
rest and in transit external connections
can be encrypted using SSL or cloud
sequel proxy which is a tool to help you
connect to your cloud sequel instance
from your local machines you can use
cloud sequel as a relational database
for your applications that are hosted
within Google cloud like App Engine and
cloud run compute engine kubernetes
engine or cloud functions you could also
connect your cloud sequel database with
applications that are hosted outside of
Google Cloud link for more details is
included below cloud sequel pricing
varies depending on my sequel for a
sequel or sequel server
broadly speaking though it's the
combination of the type of instance
storage or network you use sequel server
also has some licensing costs now what
are some of the cloud sequel use cases
since cloud sequel is a relational
database you can use it with any online
transaction processing app such as order
or payment processing apps where you
need to handle frequent queries with
fast response times want to learn more
about cloud sequel check out cloud to
google.com slash sequel